David Boder: [In German] Sie sprechen hier in dis...
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, was, eh...spreche ich?
David Boder: Ich werde Ihnen sagen. Sagen Sie mal, Polia. Wie ist Ihr voller Name?
Polia Bisenhaus: Bitte, was?
David Boder: Was ist Ihr Name?
David Boder: [In English] What’s your name?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In German] Meine Name? Polia Bisenhaus.
David Boder: Eh, noch einmal...
David Boder: [In English] Polia what?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In German] Polia Bisenhaus.
David Boder: Bisenhaus?
Polia Bisenhaus: Bisenhaus.
David Boder: Bisenhaus.
Polia Bisenhaus: [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] פֿון װוּ זײַט איר?
Polia Bisenhaus: איך? פֿון פּױלן.
David Boder: Zent fun Poland.
Polia Bisenhaus: [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Velkhe shtat in Poland?
Polia Bisenhaus: Staszów.
David Boder: Staszów?
Polia Bisenhaus: Hm.
David Boder: Was ist das: Russian—...Russisch-Polen [unklar]?
Polia Bisenhaus: דאָרט (איז) געװען רוסיש־פּױלן.
David Boder: Kommen Sie a bisl näher. Es iz gevezn Rusish-Poland?
Polia Bisenhaus: Rusish-Poyln. [umklor] Davor iz geven der krig, und jetzt ist es auch Rusish-Polen.
David Boder: Ja. Aber, eh, während dem Krieg waren die Russen dort oder...?
Polia Bisenhaus: Die Russen.
David Boder: Die Russen dort. Alright. Now...Erzählen Sie mir: Und denn, wenn sind die Russen weggegangen, und ven sind die daytshn gekumen? Zogn zi mir di gantse geshikhte!
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, איך װאַר נישט דאָרט[ן], אין...עהה...װען די רוסן זענען אַרײַנגעקומען, װאַר איך אין דעם לאַגער אין...דײַטשלאַנד. איך װאַר נישט אין סטאַשו.
David Boder: Wieso sind Sie gekommen nach daytshland?
Polia Bisenhaus: איך װאַר אין קיעלצע [קעלץ], אין [ ? אומקלאָר]...אין אײן אַרבעטס-, עה, אַמוניציע־לאַגער, עה, אַרבעטסלאַגער...איך האָב געאַרבעט אַמוניציע...נאַכהער האָט מען מיך...אין 44סטן יאָר, האָט מען מיך עװאַקויִרט נאָך דײַטשלאַנד.
David Boder: Hmhm.
Polia Bisenhaus: Mm-hm.
David Boder: Aber vu haben Sie gelebt, wenn die Russen sind gekommen?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, איך װאַר נישט, װען די רוסן...
David Boder: Sie waren nicht unter di rusn?
Polia Bisenhaus: נײן, איך בין באַפֿרײַט געװאָרן דורך די...אַמעריקאַנער...
David Boder: Ja, aber Sie waren nicht unter di rusn?
Polia Bisenhaus: נײן. איך װאַר נישט אונטער די רוסן געװען, איך בין באַפֿרײַט געװאָרן דורך די אַמעריקאַנער.
David Boder: Ja. Also in was für einem Lager waren Sie, wo [vern?] Sie in lager?
Polia Bisenhaus: אין פּױלן װאַר איך אין לאַגער, אין אײן אַרבעטסלאַגער און אין דײַטשלאַנד װאַר איך אין אײן פֿאַרניכטונגסלאַגער.
David Boder: Vernichtungslager?!
Polia Bisenhaus: [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In German/English] Alright. Erzählen Sie mir: was war das Arbeitslager?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In German/Yiddish] נו, מיר האָבן געאַרבעט, עה, 12 שטונדען אײן טאָג, אַ גאַנצן טאָג, און אײן װאָך בײַ טאָג, אײן װאָך בײַ נאַכט.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gearbayt?
Polia Bisenhaus: אַמוניציע, דאָס איז...עה, נו׃...עה, אַמוניציע!
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: [אומקלאָר]
David Boder: Aha, oh, es war eine Fabrik!
Polia Bisenhaus: [umklor] Fabrik. [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Nun, und, eh...ven Sie haben...was hat man Ihnen zu Essen gegeben?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, in Polen var es nicht schlimm, in Polen haben sie gegeben ganz gut Essen, das ist gewesen, eh...manche Tage in der Woche geveyn Fleisch, un, eh, in daytshland var es zeyer shlim.
David Boder: Aha. Aber das war in Polen. Und [In English] how long...[In German] Wie lange haben Sie gearbeitet in Polen?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In German/Yiddish] In Polen dray yor.
David Boder: Drei Jahre? Und warum hat man Sie weggenommen von dort?
Polia Bisenhaus: װען די רוסן האָבן זיך דערנענטערט, מ’האָט...אין קעלץ האָט מען אונדז געשיקט נאָך טשענסטאָכאַו, נאַכהער, װען זײ האָבן זיך דערנענטערט נאָך טשענסטאָכאַו, האָט מען אונדז געשיקט נאָך, עה...דײַטשלאַנד.
David Boder: נאָך דײַטשלאַנד?
Polia Bisenhaus: [אומקלאָר]
David Boder: Aha. Eh...weil: vorhin haben Sie gesagt, Sie waren in einem Vernichtungslager: welches Lager war das?
Polia Bisenhaus: Bergen-Belsen.
David Boder: Bergen-Belsen?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Ohhh! In, eh...und, eh...was haben Sie dort getan?
Polia Bisenhaus: ביזענהאַוס׃ דאָרט האָבן מיר גאָר נישט געטאָן, מיר זענען געזעסן און האָבן נישט באַקומען קײן עסן. צען דעקאַ ברױט אַ טאָג, אָבער דאָס איז...עה, manche Tage das Brot auch nicht...[Di veser?] haben gesagt, אַז, עה...מ’האָט באַגנבֿעט די ברױט־קאַמער, האָבן זײ נישט געגעבן קײן עסן, און װען עס איז געקומען די עס־עס, צו פֿרעגן׃ װאַרום [פֿאַר װאָס] באַקומט איר הױטע [הײַנט] נישט קײן עסן? – האָבן זײ געזאָגט, עה...האָבן זײ געזאָגט די עס־עס, אַז מיר זאָלן זאָגן׃ מיר האָבן געשטאָלט [געגנבֿעט].
David Boder: Also, Sie sollen sagen...?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja. Wir sollen sagen, [reden zur gleichen Zeit] wir haben gestohlt deriber bakumen wir heute, haben wir [Essensperre/Essenstrafe (?)].
David Boder: Aha.
Polia Bisenhaus: In deriber haben sie undz nisht gegebn kayn esn.
Polia Bisenhaus: Das war...vielmal in der Woche.
David Boder: Aha. Und, eh: wie sind Sie geschlafen, erzählen Sie...[unverständlich]?
Polia Bisenhaus: Geschlafen? Auf der Erd...Geshlafn zenen vir auf der erd...eh...das ist gewesen...a gantsn Tag zenen vir gezesn auf di erd, of deym zelbn...eh, das iz gevezn Stroh, un nakhher, bay nakht, zaynen / zen’ vir geshlafn of demzelbn ort: das war sehr schmutzig dort. fil(e?) zaynen/zenen geshtorbn fun dem shmuts, was dort war.
David Boder: Well, was haben die daytshn gesagt: was halt(n?) man Sie dortn?
Polia Bisenhaus: זײ האָבן גאָר נישט געזאָגט, װאַרום [פֿאַר װאָס] זײ האַלטן אונדז דאָרט. זײ האָבן אונדז נישט געזאָגט, אָבער מיר האָבן געװוּסט, זײ האַלטן אונדז דעריבער, װײַל זײ האָבן געװאָלט, עה...אונדז פֿאַרניכטן, אָבער...דאָס איז זײ נישט געלונגען.
David Boder: All right. Haben Sie andere Leute vernichtet dort [unverständlich]?
Polia Bisenhaus: Oui, zeyer fil. Ven di layte varen shvakher...eh...fun jeden Tag zu Tag waren dokh di leute shvakher, vayl zi habn kayn esn nisht bekumen, haben sie uns, eh...haben sie genomen...eh...farnikhtet: das war dort ein, eh, nu, kamer, vu zay hobn fargazirt und, eh...nakhher hobn zi gebrent, un das iz dokh bakant ales, was die Deutschen haben gemacht.
David Boder: Wieso ist es bekannt? In amerike weiß man sehr wenig.
Polia Bisenhaus: אוּוּוּוהה! אין אַמעריקע װײסט מען אַלץ! עה...װײַל די...די זשורנעלע [זשורנאַלן] האָבן שױן פֿיל געשריבן [װעגן דעם?]...נו, װײסט איר נישט, אָדער?
David Boder: Ja! Manche Leute wissen, manche wissen nicht...Das ist, warum ich will, dass...Haben Sie Verwandte in Amerika?
Polia Bisenhaus: Oui, ikh hab Verwandte in amerike...
David Boder: Wo sind Ihre Verwandten?
Polia Bisenhaus: עה...אײן אָנקל אין...ניו־יאָרק, און אײנער אין שיקאַגאָ.
David Boder: Sie haben einen Onkel in Chicago?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Ich bin in Chicago!
Polia Bisenhaus: “Bisenhaus”—dizelbe nomen...[ist/vi iz?] mayne...
David Boder: Bisenhaus?
Polia Bisenhaus: Bisenhaus, oui, das ist mayn fater(s?) zayn futer [feter?].
David Boder: Wollen Sie, dass ich Ihren Onkel sehen soll?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In French] Oui! [In German/Yiddish] Ikh vol...gerne im sehen, aber ikh zol/vol kommen...
David Boder: Wollen Sie, dass ich Ihren Onkel sehen soll...und mit ihm sprechen?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, ja! Warum nicht?
David Boder: Wollen Sie nach Amerika kommen?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, איך װײס נישט, איך װאָלט גערן נאָך פּאַלעסטינע פֿאָרן...
David Boder: Sie wollen gern...
Polia Bisenhaus: Vayl ikh hab dort tsvay tante, in ikh vil...farn...[Palestina?]. Beser...nokh Palestina. Ja, ikh denke, far mir vet es zayn beser vi in amerika.
David Boder: Wollen Sie etwas sagen zu Ihrem Onkel?
Polia Bisenhaus: Tsu maynen onkl?
David Boder: Ja, ich klingel ihn zu zu meinem Haus, und ich werde ihm geben...
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, wenn Sie wollen...Soll ich ihm/Höre ich ihn...was er spricht?
David Boder: No, no, was Sie sprechen.
Polia Bisenhaus: Was ich sprech, vet er hern?
David Boder: Ja.
Polia Bisenhaus: Und, eh...was er sprecht, vel ikh nisht...?
David Boder: Nein, nein, nein.
Polia Bisenhaus: אָה, דאָס איז נישט גוט! איך װיל אים אױך הערן!
David Boder: [In English] No, no, no. [In German] Sie können jetzt einfach was sagen: wie in einem Radio—Sie können...
Polia Bisenhaus: אָבער איך װײס נישט זײַן אַדרעס.
David Boder: Oh, Ich werde ihn finden.
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja?
David Boder: Ja! Ich werde ihn finden. Sie werden [In English] me later [In German/Yiddish] die Adresse geben, ich werde es aufschreiben, und ich werde ihn finden.
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, יעצט שױן? [...אומקלאָר]
David Boder: Nein, nein, nicht diesen Moment. Sie sprechen, was Sie Ihrem Onkel sagen wollen. Und wenn ich nach Chicago komm’, dann nehm’ ich die Maschine...und er wird zu mein’ Haus kommen und ich werde ihm das zugeben, was Sie ihm sagen!
Polia Bisenhaus: So? Und ven komen Sie nach, eh...zu Hause?
David Boder: Fünf Wochen.
Polia Bisenhaus: פֿינף װאָכן?
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, ס’איז גוט!
David Boder: Nur sagen Sie, was Sie sagen wollen! [lachen]
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . [umklor]...in dizem moment sagen, un ven ikh kan mit ihm sprechen, hab ikh im fil tsu sagen!
David Boder: Zum Beispiel: was wollen Sie Ihrem Onkel sagen?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, װאָס איך װיל [ / ? װײס איך װאָל?], װאָס ער מאַכט, װאָס ער טוט איצט...!
David Boder: Aha. Wollen Sie, dass er was für Sie tun soll?
Polia Bisenhaus: Für Sie?
David Boder: Wollen Sie, dass er etwas für Sie tun soll? Hat er Ihnen Geld geschickt?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu! Er shikt mir, ja!
David Boder: Er shikt Ihnen...?
Polia Bisenhaus: [...אומקלאָר] (איך װיל נישט, ?) ער זאָל מיר שיקן איצט אַ...איך לערן זיך אַ פֿאַך, איך װיל מיר זעלבסט מיר פֿאַרדינען, (איך זאָל קענען...)
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: דאָס איז דאָך נישט...דער אָנקל זאָל מיר שיקן...װעט ער שיקן אײן מאָל, צװײ מאָל, דרײַ מאָל...[אומקלאָר – אָבער דאָס װערט דאָך ניט, נו?]
Polia Bisenhaus: [...? סע דאָך ניט קראַנק?]...[אומקלאָר] נאָר איך װיל זײַן זעלבשטענדיק, װיל איך פֿאַרדינען...
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter. Eh, iz er a reicher Mann, Ihr Onkel?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja! Er ist nicht...orem...
David Boder: Wieviel Wo—, eh, wieviel Monate waren Sie in Bergen...Belsen?
Polia Bisenhaus: דאָ אין בעלזען װאַר איך, עה...דרײַ מאָנאַטע. בעלזען.
David Boder: יאָ. דרײַ, דרײַ מאָנאַטע?
Polia Bisenhaus: דרײַ מאָנאַטע.
David Boder: [In English] And, eh...eh...[In German/Yiddish] Waren viele layte vernichtet dort?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, זײער פֿילע זענען געשטאָרבן, װײַל מיר האָבן...אױף אַן אַפּעל...
David Boder: Hm.
Polia Bisenhaus: Wissen Sie, was ein Appell ist?
David Boder: Ja.
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . האָבן אַרױסגערופֿן לײַט [מענטשן], זײ האָבן [זענען] געגאַנגען גאַנץ נאַקעט, נישט אָנגעטאָן...דאָס איז געװעזן
David Boder: Warum [umklor: (hatten sie...nisht un...?)]
Polia Bisenhaus: זײ האָבן צוגענומען אַלעס, װאָס מיר האָבן נאָך פֿון דער הײם געהאַט, אַלע...קלײדער...און זײ האָבן געגעבן אַזױ מיט די שטרײַפֿן...
David Boder: Ja.
Polia Bisenhaus: [umklor]...vas [= vays]...fun klayder [umklor: (vus mer...vas...zen fun di klayder - ?!)] eh...un shiekh, un shtrimf [= Strümpfe], in vir zen’ azoy gegangen in di größte...yanuar: in di größte keltn, yanuar, februar: das sind di größte keltn, zenen vir gegangen gants naket in deriber zenen fil geshtorbn! un esn, in eh...nisht geshlufn, nisht zikh gevashn, in deriber zenen fil geshtorbn!
David Boder: Haben die, eh...eh...Nazis...die...Frauen, eh...beleidigt, haben sie sie...be—...?
Polia Bisenhaus: Geschlagen?
David Boder: Nein, ich meine, haben sie, waren sie unanständig mit de Frauen?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, das iz, das iz farshtendlekh!
David Boder: [In English] What do you mean “iz farshtendlekh”?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] נו, אַז...זײ האָבן זיך באַצױגן זײער נישט גוט צו די פֿרױען! און זײ האָבן פֿיל מאָל אױף זײ געשלאָגן...װען מיר זענען נישט גלײַך געשטאַנען אױף דעם אַפּעל, װײַל אונדז איז...[אומקלאָר], װען עס װאַר קאַלט, אײנע האָט צוגעלײגט זיך אױף דעם צװײטן, האָבן זײ געשלאָגן, זײ האָבן...איבערן קאָפּ און אַזױ...[אומקלאָר]
David Boder: Eh...Nu, sagen Sie zum Beispiel, eh: Was hat man den ganzen Tag in Belsen getan? Sagen wir, am Morgen sind Sie aufgestanden—um wieviel Uhr?
Polia Bisenhaus: אין מאָרגן איז געװען אַן אַפּעל צום אױפֿשטײן, עה...פֿיר אור [= 4 אַ זײגער], דרײַ אור...פֿינף אור...
David Boder: Nu?
Polia Bisenhaus: Haben vir gegangen zikh vashn, un vashn iz geveyzn ayn, eh, tsimer, zeyer a klayns: kalt vaser. Gunts kalt, un vir zenen arayngangen gonts naket, un fil hobn zikh erkeltet [erkältet], zeyer fil...
David Boder: Ja.
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . און דער אָרגאַניזם איז שװאַך׃ מע עסט נישט, מע װאַשט זיך מיט קאַלט װאַסער...
David Boder: Waren dort Männer oder Frauen, das haben Sie...[unverständlich]?
Polia Bisenhaus: [umklor: (Frauen?)] Das waren die...
David Boder: Nein, nein, ich meine die Nazis.
Polia Bisenhaus: Die Nazis? Das waren Frauen und, eh, Männer, aber die Frauen zenen fil shlimer/schlimmer, varen fil shlimer/schlimmer fir undz vi di mener.
David Boder: Wieso?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, di frauen habn geshlogen...zeyer...zeyer geferlekh! ze haben geshlagen, ze haben zikh erlaubt...es varen fil Juden, [umklor: terkishe?] und rumener,...vas zaynen auch...vas zaynen geveyzn...di lagerfirer, Lagerälteste...In di zenen nokh fil ar-, erger geveyn vi di da—, vi di Natsis.
David Boder: Sie meinen, das zaynen Juden lagerfirnde...?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja!
David Boder: Und...
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . un di yuden, zi waren sehr schlimm für uns. Sehr schlimm!
David Boder: Wie: die Juden waren lagerfirnde und die haben...
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, ja, zey habn sehr shlim zikh bagangen mit undz.
David Boder: Tsu di andere Juden.
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja. Zeyer shlim.
David Boder: Nu, eh...sagen Sie: [vus?] sind Sie aufgestanden um drei, vier in de Morgen und Sie sind gegangen, haben sich gewaschen: den was?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, נאַכהער האָבן די...האָבן...געברענגט קאַװע, שװאַרצע קאַװע...פֿיל מאָל האָבן דאָס אױך נישט באַקומען...און, אָן ברױט.
David Boder: Ohne Brot. [In English] All right...
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] Nakhher, eh...tsvelef ur, halb tsvelf, elf, [...vi ayn mal (?)] iz es gevezn Mittagsstunde. De Mittagsstunde i’ gevezn: ayn bisschen [In English] soup, [In Yiddish/German] drayfertl liter, velkhes mal a halbn liter, in, eh, velkhes mal a halbn liter auch nisht...in, eh, das ist gewesen mit ribn. Manche...dray shtiklekh ribn, az me hot gefinen in a sup: i’ gevezn zeyer gut. i’ sho’ ge’[veyn] a gite sup.
David Boder: Yo.
Polia Bisenhaus: Un nakhher, eh...finef ur, fir ur, manches Mal zeks ur: iz gevezn broyt. Ayn shtikchen broyt, das iz geveyzn azoy lang broyt, tsetaylt of tsen man, of tsvelef man...
David Boder: Hm...
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . איז געװעזן...אױסגעקומען פֿאַר אַכט דעקאַ ברױט, צען דעקאַ ברױט אַ טאָג. דאָס איז געװען דאָס עסן.
David Boder: Un den in avnt? Un den, nach dem Essen, was haben Sie getan?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, nakhher...zen’ wir gezesn, vayter! - Vi a gantsn Tag! [...? umklor] nakhn apel var es, eh, das Mittag.
David Boder: Hmhm.
Polia Bisenhaus: דאָס...דער אַפּעל װאַר, עה, אין יעדן טאָג.
David Boder: Was, eh nennen Sie de Appell? Was [In English] was the Appell?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German]דער אַפּעל צײלט, עה...אױב עס איז װער אַנטלאָפֿן, אָדער װער עס איז געשטאָרבן׃ דאָס איז מע זאָל װיסן גענױ, װיפֿל עס איז דאָ איבערצוגעבן װײַטער, װיפֿל עס געפֿינט זיך אין לאַגער.
David Boder: Aha.
Polia Bisenhaus: װיפֿל פֿרױען, מענער...נו...דאַס װאַר, עה...פֿיל מאָל דער אַפּעל האָט געדױערט פֿיר, פֿינף שעה. און פֿיל מענטשן זײַנען אױפֿן אַפּעל געפֿאַלן...אַז מען איז...פֿון דער קעלט און פֿון מידקײט...הונגער
David Boder: Und was hat man mit ihnen/denen gemacht?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, נאַכהער זײַנען מיר געגאַנגען...פֿיל מאָל האָבן זײ נאָך דעם אַפּעל – פֿינף שעה שטײן אָט אין דרױסן – האָבן זײ גענומען אױף אַרבעט. די אַרבעט איז געװעזן צו טראָגן שטעק, שטעק...עה...פֿאַרשידן האָלץ, פֿון אײן אָרט אױפֿן צװײטן. דאָס איז געװעזן...אָבער די אַרבעט איז געװען גאָר נישט, אָבער זײ האָבן פֿיל מאָל געשלאָגן, װען מיר האָבן נישט געקענט אַזױ שנעל לױפֿן, און אַזױ װײַטער...
David Boder: Hmhm. Na, sagen Sie mal: war der Doktor dort [unverständlich]?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, es war ein Dokter, ayn, eh...dentist...azo...
David Boder: Ein dentist? Hat er sie...was getan, zu die...zu die...Gefangene, hat er was getan?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, ער האָט אַרױסגענומען די צײן בלױז, אַרױסגעריסן, אױב װער עס האָט געהאַט [שלים?] צײן־שמאַרץ, -שמערץ, האָט ער אַרױסגענומען [צונער? (= צײן)].
David Boder: [In English/Yiddish] Was it a daytsher doctor, or...?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] נו, עס װאַר אַ דײַטשער דאָקטער, און עס װאַר אַ ייִדישער דאָקטער...
David Boder: אַ ייִדישער דאָקטער?
Polia Bisenhaus: ייִדישער.
David Boder: Aha. [In English] And, eh...[In German/Yiddish] Sagen Sie, eh...un den, wie sind Sie befreit gevordn?
Polia Bisenhaus: באַפֿרײַט געװאָרן בין איך בײַ דאַכאַו. פֿון די אַמעריקאַנער.
David Boder: Wieso? Hat man Sie von Belsen geschickt...?
Polia Bisenhaus: פֿון בעלזען נאַכהער געװעזן נאָך אין דרײַ לאַגערן.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, welche...
Polia Bisenhaus: [פֿון?] בעלזען בין איך געװעזן אין בורגאַו, נאַכהער אין טירקענהײַם.
David Boder: [In English] Yes...
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] אין בורגאַו װאַר איך, עה...דרײַ װאָכן...אָדער פֿיר װאָכן...נאַכהער אין טירקהײַם װאַר איך צװײ װאָכן. נאַכהער האָט מ’איבערגעפֿירט, װען די אַמעריקאַנדער האָבן זיך שױן דערנענטערט, האָט מען איבערגעפֿירט נאָך, עה...דאַכאַו. און דאָרטן זענען מיר באַפֿרײַט געװאָרן.
David Boder: Aha.
Polia Bisenhaus: In, eh...30stn...
David Boder: Was, eh...wie hat man Sie gefirt fun, fun [eyn?] lager tsum andern: in, eh...af der Eisenbahn, [In English] by...truck, by...[In German/Yiddish] was?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, פֿון עה...פֿון בער־, פֿון בערגען־בעלזען נאָך, עה, בורגאַו זענען מיר געפֿאָרן אױף, עה...װאַגאָן, יאָ.
David Boder: In de vagonen?
Polia Bisenhaus: Vagon, yo.
David Boder: Eh...wie lange hat das gedauert?
Polia Bisenhaus: עה, דאָס האָט געדױערט, עה, גאַנצע אַכט טעג. אַכט טעג האָט געדױערט דאָס, די רײַזע.
David Boder: Eh...
Polia Bisenhaus: מיר האָבן קײן עסן נישט באַקומען, אױף די װעגן, און ס’איז געװעזן באָמבאַרדירן...און...זײער פֿיל זענען פֿון די באָמבעס דערהאַרגעט געװאָרן...
David Boder: Sind Leute ge—...Sind Leute geharget gevorn?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, ja.
David Boder: [Wie var dos (?)/ Wieso dos (?)]...di bombes gefaln...
Polia Bisenhaus: די באָמבעס געפֿאַלן, יאָ...
David Boder: Aufn Zug...
Polia Bisenhaus: אױפֿן צוג און, עה, װער עס האָט נישט געקענט אַנטלױפֿן, איז געפֿאַלן אונטער די באָמבן [באָמבעס].
David Boder: [vayl? well?] Wie haben Sie kenen antloyfn, ven Sie waren im Zug?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, װען...פֿון דער צװײטער זײַט...(דאַר־?)אונטער דעם װאַגאָן...
David Boder: דער צוג איז געשטאַנען?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, װען דער צוג װאַר באָמבאַרדירט, איז דער צוג נישט געפֿאָרן.
David Boder: Aha.
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . איז געשטאַנען...
David Boder: Un di, eh...Nazis sind auch...?
Polia Bisenhaus: די נאַציס זענען אַנטלאָפֿן, זײ האָבן זיך באַהאַלטן, זײ האָבן [אומקלאָר] געשאָפֿן, אַרױפֿגעשאָסן צו די...אַװיאָנען, און ס’איז...
David Boder: Ja. Und sie haben gelassen, dass Sie sich verstecken sollen?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, זײ האָבן נישט געזען! זײ האָבן...זענען אַלײן געװעזן צעמישט, װײַל זײ האָבן אַלײן געװאָלט זיך...עה...אַנטלױפֿן און...
David Boder: Aha. Und/von? da sind Sie acht Tage gegangen: von wo?
Polia Bisenhaus: Acht Tage sind wir gegangen fin, eh Türkenheim nukh Dachau.
David Boder: Türkenheim nach Dachau.
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja.
David Boder: [In English] Alright, [In German/Yiddish] nu erzählen Sie mir: Sind Sie gekommen in Dachau: was hat man dort gemacht?
Polia Bisenhaus: אין דאַכאַו איז שױן געװעזן אַ פּאָר טעג פֿאַרן באַפֿרײַען, האָט...מיר זײַנען אָנגעקומען, האָבן די עס־עס געזאָגט, צו די פֿירערס, צו די צװײ, װאָס האָבן אונדז געפֿירט: [דײַטש׃] װאַרום האַט איר די לױטע געבראַכט? איך בראַוך זי נישט. [ייִדיש] און האָבן זײ געזאָגט׃ מיר װײסן נישט. װאָלט זײ, װאָלט זײ פֿאַרשטעקן. [דײַטש:] װאַס זאָללען װיר מאַכען מיט דיזע לױטע? [ייִדיש׃] האָט דער עס־עס־פֿירער געזאָגט׃ [ייִדיש/דײַטש:] אַה, איך װײס שױן, װאַס מיט די לױטע צו מאַכען! [ייִדיש׃] האָט ער אונדז אױסגעשטעלט, און מיר האָבן געדענקט, אַז זײ גײען אונדז אױסשיסן, װײַל ס’איז געװעזן נאַטירלעך – װי זײ האָבן געטאָן מיט אַלע ייִדן. נאָר, נאַכהער איז געקומען עפּעס אַ באַפֿעל, און זײ זענען אַנטלאָפֿן...[אומקלאָר] װער איז אַנטלאָפֿן? און נאַכהער האָט מען אונדז אַרײַנגעשיקט אין אַ בלאָק, סע געװײזן...
David Boder: [Vus heyst dus? / Di SSers?]
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, ס’איז שױן...די עס־עס, װאָס האָט פֿאַרנומען שױן [אומקלאָר], שױן...ייִדסן האָבן שױן אָנגעהױבן צו איבערנעמען/באַנעמען, מע האָט שױן געזען, אַז ס’דערנענטערט זיך שױן די באַפֿרײַונג...האָבן זײ אונדז אַרײַנגעפֿירט אין אַ בלאָק און, עה...מ’האָט זיך דאָרט דאַן געלײגט – זענען מיר געװען מיד פֿון אַכט טעג גײן צו פֿוס – און נאַכהער...צו מאָרגנס, מע איז אַרױס געגאַנגען, האָט מען שאָזן נישט געזען קײן אײן עס־עס׃ אַלע זענען שױן [געהאַט?] אַװעק, און דאָס...אין דער הײ דאָרטן, װוּ די עס־עס זענען געשטאַנען שטענדיק, און זײ האָבן [אומקלאָר] – איז שױן געשטאַנען ייִדישע העפֿטלינגע
David Boder: Yidishe...?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ. ידישע העפֿטלינגע. ביקסנס האָבן זײ באַנומען פֿון די...פֿון די...נאַציס.
David Boder: Aha.
Polia Bisenhaus: – מע האָט שױן געזען אַז דערנענטערט זיך, נאַכהער האָבן דאָס די נאַציס [אומקלאָר]...אױס...װיפֿיל ייִדן נאָך געװען דאָ, אָבער עס איז זײ נישט געלונגען, װײַל די אַמעריקאַנער זענען געקומען.
David Boder: Di amerikaner. So, wieviel Tage waren Sie in Dachau?
Polia Bisenhaus: אין דאַכאַו װאַר איך, עה, דרײַ װאָכן – נאָך דער באַפֿרײַונג.
David Boder: Aha.
Polia Bisenhaus: Nakhher...
David Boder: Aber [noch?/be-?/da-?]vor der Befreiung: wie lange waren Sie...
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, װאַר איך צװײ טעג [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: 2 Tage bloß in Dachau?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja. Ja. 2 Tage.
David Boder: Und dann war die Befreiung.
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ. װאַר די באַפֿרײַונג און מיר זענען געװעזן באַפֿרײַט פֿון די אַמעריקאַנער, און דאָס װאַר שױן גוט!
David Boder: Ja. Hat man arrestiert...die SS dort, wenn die Amerikaner sind gekommen?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ. מ’האָט פֿיל אַרעסטירט, אָבער די אַמעריקאַנער האָבן זײ גאָר נישט געטאָן. װען מ’האָט דערקענט אַן עס־עס, װאָס ער האָט, עה...[אומקלאָר]...איז האָבן די אַמעריקאַנער נישט געלאָזט [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: די אַמעריקאַנער...?
Polia Bisenhaus: האָבן נישט געלאָזט צו טאָן [גאָר נישט (?)].
David Boder: Zey hobn nisht erlaubt...
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, sie haben nisht erlaubt.
David Boder: אַה. צו טאָן זײ עפּעס.
Polia Bisenhaus: [In English] No.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Aha. So, wo haben die yidishe layte bekomen de biksn [umklor: (un nokh vas?/un al das?)]?
Polia Bisenhaus: זײ האָבן נישט באַקומען, זײ האָבן אַלײן גענומען פֿון די נאַציס, װען זײ האָבן אַװעקגעװאָרפֿן די, די...ביקסן -
David Boder: Oh.
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . האָבן זײ עס אַלײן גענומען!
David Boder: [In German/English] Aha. So. And wie...and then...wieso sind Sie gekommen nach Paris?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] נאָך פּאַריז? האָט מיך דער אָנקל מיט דער טאַנטע אַהערגענומען.
David Boder: Fun vu, in Paris?
Polia Bisenhaus: Fun, eh...Ja, sie wohnen hier, eh...
David Boder: Oh, sie haben hier in Paris gelebt?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, in Paris...[umklor].
David Boder: Haben Sie gehat den die Adresse?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, איך האָב נישט געהאַט די אַדרעסע, נאָר זײ האָבן זיך דערװוּסט פֿון אַ [אומקלאָר], אױף אַ ליסט...
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . װאָס מ’האָט איבערגעשיקט פֿון לאַגער, האָט מען זיך דערװוּסט פֿון אַמעריקע, דער אָנקל האָט זיך אָפּגעפֿרעגט [אומקלאָר] נאָך פּאַריז, װער דאָס איז, די ביזענהאַוס [אומקלאָר (...געזען אױף דער ליסט?)]. האָבן אונדז נישט געװוּסט, װײַל זײ האָבן מיך נישט געקענט...אַז איך בין אַװעק, בין איך געװעזן זײער יונג, נו, נאַכהער האָבן זיך...
David Boder: [אומקלאָר]
Polia Bisenhaus: נאַכהער האָבן זײ זיך דערװוּסט, האָבן זײ מיך אַהערגענומען.
David Boder: Haben Sie ahergenumen aus Paris. Und wie lange sind Sie in Paris?
Polia Bisenhaus: אין פּאַריז בין איך זעקס מאָנאַט.
David Boder: 6 monat? [In English] And [In German/Yiddish] Sie wollen gehen nach Palestina?
Polia Bisenhaus: Hm.
David Boder: Beser den nakh amerike.
Polia Bisenhaus: Beser den nakh amerike.
David Boder: Vu haben Sie...wen haben Sie dort in...eh...
Polia Bisenhaus: אין פּאַלעסטינע האָב איך צװײ טאַנטעס.
David Boder: און װוּ?
Polia Bisenhaus: [אומקלאָר] זײ װױנען אין...האַדעראַ.
David Boder: In Hadera? Und Sie denken, dass sie können Sie...eh, tsunemen oder...
Polia Bisenhaus: איך דענק. זײ קענען מיך נישט, נאָר איך מוז דורך אַ קיבוץ...דורך הכשרה מוז איך...[אומקלאָר].
David Boder: Durch [In English] what?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] דורך אַ הכשרה. דורך אַ קיבוץ. [אומקלאָר]
David Boder: Verstehen Sie [In English] Hebrew?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] נו, איך קען נישט, איך האָב געקענט אַ ביסל – איך [האָב] דאָך פֿאַרגעסן, װײַל איך לערן זיך פֿראַנצױזיש און...
David Boder: Sie lernen sich Französisch hier? Und die/Ihr Onkel und Tante leben hier schon lange [in Paris (?)]?
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, sie sind shoyn hier 17 yor.
David Boder: Aha. Eh...ich will Sie noch etwas bitten.
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja?
David Boder: Wenn ikh, eh...ikh bin a profesor und ikh studiere diese Sachen, verstehen Sie? Aber, ich will sehen, Sie werden mir geben die Adresse von Ihrem Onkel und von der...
Polia Bisenhaus: אָבער די גענױע אַדרעסע האָב איך נישט, נאָר...
David Boder: [אומקלאָר]
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . האָב איך אין דער הײם.
David Boder: Ah, ich vil kimen morgn und ibermorgn und so on (?)...
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja, ja. Kumt ir...hier...morgn auch?
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: װעל איך ברענגען מײַן אַדרעסע...
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . פֿון מײַן אָנקל, פֿון...יאָ?
David Boder: Ja. Und ich werde Ihren Onkel dann besuchen...
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ. דאָס איז זײער אינטערעסאַנט...איר װעט איבערגעבן אַ גרוס, איר האָט מיך געזען אין אָר”ט...עה...
David Boder: Ja. Er wird sich sehr freuen.
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, יאָ! איך, עה...נאַטירלעך!
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish/English] [unintelligible]...this? Eh...This is a bild from a berimtn, eh...eh...kinstler. From di letzte 3 Jahre, was Sie sich haben derlebt: was denken Sie, meint dies Bild?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] נו, דאָס בילד איז פֿון, פֿון אַ פֿרױ, װי, גלײב איך, אַז מע האָט זי דעפּאָרטירט און זי האָט אַלעס פֿאַרלױרן, און זי איז פֿאַרצװײפֿלט, זי קלערט װאָס צו טאָן, זי האָט נישט קײן אױסװעג.
David Boder: Hm. Und was denken Sie, is this bild?
Polia Bisenhaus: Das bild, das iz...auch fun de krig, un...das ist far de krig [or no?]?
David Boder: Ja...Nu...?
Polia Bisenhaus: דאָס איז...דאָס מוז זײַן...נו, אַ [אומקלאָר].
David Boder: Ja. Und was denken Sie, hat ihm passiert?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, אױך דאָס זעלבע – ער האָט אַלעס פֿאַרלױרן, די, די...די גאַנצע פֿאַמיליע – איז געבליבן אַלײן, אַזױ װי איך...איך בין אױך געבליבן אַלײן פֿון דער גאַנצער פֿאַמיליע. דאָס!
David Boder: Was is dis/this?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, דאָס איז, עה, דענק איך – איך װײס נישט, אױב ס’איז..., אױב דאָס שטימט!
David Boder: Ja. Aber natürlich. Was denken Sie?
Polia Bisenhaus: איך דענק, אַז ער װײנט נאָך זײַן פֿרױ, װי זי איז געשטאָרבן, אָדער דאָס איז זײַן טאָכטער, איך װײס נישט גענױ...[אומקלאָר (איך קען זען נישט די אױגן [?])]
David Boder: Und was denken Sie, [In English] is this?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In German/Yiddish] Das?...[umklor]
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter...
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . צו אַנטלױפֿן, נו, װוּ צו באַהאַלטן...[נו, און אַלעס פֿעלט אים (?)].
David Boder: Und was denken Sie, [In English] is this?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In German/Yiddish] Das...nu, di arbet...[umklor]
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Polia Bisenhaus: . . . מע אַרבעט, אין פֿעלד!
David Boder: Wo, denken Sie [In English], is this?
Polia Bisenhaus: [In Yiddish/German] נו, דאָס איז נישט פּאַלעסטינע? נו! פֿילײַכט! פֿילײַכט איז פּאַלעסטינע! יאָ. דאָס איז זײער שײן. מע אַרבעט, יאָ? אַ חלוץ אַרבעט אין פֿעלד. נו, דאָס איז זײער שײן!
David Boder: Sagen Sie, haben Sie eine Vater und Mutter?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, מײַן פֿאָטער און מוטער – דעפּאָרטירט. די גאַנצע פֿאַמיליע דעפּאָרטירט...
David Boder: Wenn hat men sie deportiert?
Polia Bisenhaus: צװײ און פֿערציקסטן יאָר.
David Boder: Ven Sie weren noch in Kielce?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, װען איך װאַר אין, עה, אין קיעלצע [קעלץ]. איך װאַר נאָך אין דער הײַם. נאָר איך בין געשיקט פֿון קעלץ האָט מען אונדז [געברענגט (?)] פֿון אונדזער שטאָט אין אַ, עה...פֿון...סע געװעזן...אַ שאָפּ – דאָס איז...פֿון אַלע פֿאַכן...
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, בין איך אַרײַן אין אַזאַ מין שאָפּ, האָב באַצאָלט געלט, מע האָט מיך אַרײַנגענומען דאָ...און נאַכהער, נאָך אַכט טעג [,,, אומקלאָר] בין איך געװעזן אין, עה...שאָפּ, נאַכהער האָט מען מיך געשיקט נאָך, עה, קעלץ.
David Boder: [אומקלאָר]
Polia Bisenhaus: און מײַן פֿאַמיליע האָט מען דעפּאָרטירט – איך װײס נישט, װוּ זײ זענען.
David Boder: װען האָט מען דעפּאָרטירט די פֿאַמיליע?
Polia Bisenhaus: צװײ און פֿערציק, דאָס איז, עה, נו...װי הײסט...
David Boder: Nu, aber ich meine: wie lange, nachdem di daytshn sind gekumen, hot men deportirt di familye?
Polia Bisenhaus: אָה, די דײַטשן זענען געקומען, עה, אין נײַן און דרײַסיק! נײַן און דרײַסיק.
David Boder: יאָ.
Polia Bisenhaus: און די עלטערן האָט מען דעפּאָרטירט אין צװײ און פֿערציק.
David Boder: די עלטערן האָט מען דעפּאָרטירט אין צװײ און פֿערציק.
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja. ’42.
David Boder: Waren Sie zu Hause, ven men hot zi hat deportirt?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, ikh var gar nisht zu Hause.
David Boder: Sie waren in Kelts [Kielce].
Polia Bisenhaus: Ja.
David Boder: Hatten Sie, haben Sie Brüder und Schwestern?
Polia Bisenhaus: איך האָב געהאַט...הײַנט האָב איך נישט קײן [אומקלאָר (מער געזען [?] / מיט די זעקס (?)] פֿון דער גאַנצער פֿאַמיליע.
David Boder: װיפֿיל ברידער און שװעסטער האָט איר געהאַט?
Polia Bisenhaus: איך האָב געהאַט צװײ ברידער און דרײַ שװעסטער...
David Boder: In wo sind sie?
Polia Bisenhaus: דעפּאָרטירט! צװײ ברידער װאַרען אין, עה...[אומקלאָר] און זענען מער נישטאָ. פֿילײַכט [מען זײ (?)] דערמאָרדעט [אומקלאָר – אין סטאַרשוס? סטאַלשוס?]...
David Boder: Hmhm.
Polia Bisenhaus: [umklor]
David Boder: Was...soll ich Ihrem Onkel in Chicago sagen?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, was ihr wollt sagen! Nu, ir hat...
David Boder: Sind Sie glücklich hier?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, יאָ, איך בין זײער גוט בײַ מײַן טאַנטע, בײַ מײַן אָנקל...
David Boder: Aha. Und Sie studieren hier...Sie lernen im ORT?
Polia Bisenhaus: יאָ, איך לערן זיך אין אָר”ט סוטיען גאָרזש.
David Boder: Was is it?
Polia Bisenhaus: סוטיען גאָרזש לערן איך זיך.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Polia Bisenhaus: דאָס איז...קאָרסעטן און, עה...נו, סוטיען גאָרזש – פֿאַר, פֿאַר פֿרױען.
David Boder: Und was machen Sie am Tage?
Polia Bisenhaus: Nu, am Tage makh ikh gar nisht, heute makh ikh gar nisht.
David Boder: Sie arbeiten nicht?
Polia Bisenhaus: נו, איך אַרבעט נישט, איך בין בײַ דער טאַנטע.
David Boder: [In English] This is a record of Polia Bisenhaus taken at the ORT school, evening course, on July 29th, in Paris, 1946.